(cheering in the background)
*Cheering*
Jack: Ar-Are we sitting?
Jack: K..
Bob: Okay
Markiplier: Should we stand?
Bob talking to Jack-
Jack: I don't know.
Bob: We should do everything you do. That was the plan, Right?
Mark: Oh, okay.
Mark: Oh, Jack come on now... Come on Jack..
*Laughing*
Mark: Alright.. Hello!
Mark: Hi, how are you?
Jack: Hi.
Mark: Welcome to "Markiplier and Friends."
Wade: We're friends.
Bob: That's right.
Mark: Friend...Friend.. and Friend three over there.
Jack: Hi.
*Laughing*
Mark: Thank you all so much for coming out. It is actually packed in here except the upper rows
Mark: But, I don't know why those are vacant.
Mark: I guess we aren't popular enough
Mark: It's okay. You guys came and that's what matters, so.
Mark: Well thanks so much for being here
Mark: Umm. I don't know
Mark: We didn't plan anything on the way out here
Mark: We never do on these panels, so. *Wade's voice in the bakground*
Mark: Generally speaking, this is going to be semi- Q&A, Semi- Just crap.
Mark: Uh
Mark: We are going to make up a bunch of stuff.. Aww look Bob!
Mark: Fishcone for the win!
Bob: Aw yeah!
Mark: No one else can see what that is that we're looking at..
Wade: I hate that stupid Fishcone
Mark: That's the best strategy
Wade: It eluded me for so long
Mark: Yeah
Mark: So once again thank you all once again for being so dedicated
Mark: Um..
Mark: I don't know.. Do you guys have any profound things to say in the beginning of this to warm everybody up?
Mark: To the wonders that is--
Jack: I'm just friend three..
Jack: So I got nothing..
*laughter*
Mark: Oh, Bob you were Wade yesterday..
Mark: No one even knew who you were..
Jack: What?! (crowd awws)
Mark: Okay, that came out a lot meaner!
Mark: That was actually a thing that happened!
Mark: Don't you remember!?
Bob: No...
Mark: Don't leave me in the lurch here! I'm not an asshole!
Mark: That happened!
Bob: I'm going to pretend that I have no idea what you're talking about..
Bob: Why would you say that to me?!
Mark: I don't know..
Bob: Or Wade?
Wade: You leave me out of this!
Bob: He used you as an insult. It's not like that---
Mark: I didn't use him as an insult! I'm just saying! You were mistaken for Wade!
Wade: Wouldn't be the first time..
Jack: What did happen?
Wade: I don't know!
Mark: It's literally a small anecdote I don't know why we are making a big deal out of it!
Mark: Someone mistook you for Wade, and that's it!
Jack: So someone mistook me as your producer...
Mark: Oh cool!
Jack: They're like "Ar-Are you the producer on the animations?
Jack: I'm like " I have no idea what you're talking about."
Wade: Years ago-uh-
Mark: why that specific role...
Jack: I don't know!
Wade: Bob and I were the camera crew for Markiplier at one of the coventions we went to at one point
Bob: Yeah
Wade (deep voice): Are you Mark's camera crew?
Bob: Sure,
Mark: Why not?
Mark: You could be..
Wade: Well, it would be really hard for us to get the good angle..
Bob: To get down that low
Mark in a soft voice: Fair..
Bob: Yeahh! *Highfives Wade*
Bob: He's short
*Wade Laughing*
Bob: Yeahh!
Mark: What about him!? *Points to Jack*
Bob + Wade: He's fine..
Mark: He's Irish.. *Mumbles*
Jack: I'm fine, I'm okay..
Jack: I'm dainty!
Mark: Yeah...
Wade: Does that mean like..fresh?
Jack: No!
Bob: Yes, Yes that's--Irish for fresh...
Wade: You do say wheely bin
Mark: Oh--Speak some Irish...
Jack:  Dia duit a cairde (hello my friends)
Mark: Wha?
Bob: I do
Jack: See, nobody cares!
*laughter*
Mark: Speak some Korean!
Jack: annyeonghaseyo (hello)
Mark: I can't do that and I actually am that
Jack: Speak some German!
Mark: Uh..Eh.. Nein (No)..
Jack: Nailed it!
Mark: Thanks man! Thanks man!
Mark: Okay.. You warmed up enough? That was--
*crowd cheers*
Mark: That was our entire comedy bit.. So Uh..
Mark: So now we are going to pass it off.. Wade has something he would like to say to all of you!
Wade: Yeah, so, um..
Wade: It's really awesome having you guys all out here
Wade: This is- how many panels have we done together now?
Wade: We started- was it at Prime or East?
Mark: It was here, was the first one.
Wade: Yeah, we did the original Markiplier and Friends like-
Mark: It was the really messed up one where I told everyone that you didn't need a PAX badge to get in here.
Wade: Yeah that's right
*Bob laughs*
Wade: and I was Lord mini-
Wade: Lord space minion 7 7
Mark (laughing): Lord space minion
Wade: Yeah Lord space minion, yeah
Mark: it was a good panel
Wade: But uh,
Wade: No it's really awesome having everybody come out
Wade: and it's crazy to see how much it's grown over the last few years
Wade: Um, we're coming close- Molly and I have been dating now for almost four years
Wade: As of September fourteenth
*crowd cheers*
Wade: So-
Wade: and we're also approaching the da-
Wade: uh, the day where we recorded the Drunk Minecraft episodes, where I actually asked her out. So.
*crowd cheers*
Wade: Uh, Molly! Come up here.
Wade: over there
*crowd cheers*
Mark: over that way
Wade: Um. So,
I started my youtube channel because of what, um,
Mark and Bob and I had done with Drunk Minecraft
and you guys subscribing and finding me there
and I didn't start it until she and I met and had started dating
uh, I can't remember, it's November 19th I think
I just went over it in a million subs video, which
I just hit a million subscribers too recently which is pretty cool
*crowd cheers*
But
Uh, these guys have been with me
And Jack, since we met Jack's been with us
Uh, since the beginning
But, Molly's been there and been a part of my youtube career
She's encouraged me from the beginning
Hey
Uh so I have a question for you Molly
We've been together for-
*crowd cheers*
Mark: Step out in front. Step out in front of it
Wade: We've been together for a while now, and...
I'm trying my best to hold it together- don't- don't encourage me to cry
for a long time,
I had to sneak away from you to call your dad and get permission for this
*crowd awws*
But-
I would love to know
*crowd cheers*
*softly* If you would marry me?
*crowd cheering*
*Barely audible*  Molly: Who wouldn't want to marry you?
*Crowd Cheering*
Wade: -it fit?
Wade: I think you messed up my mic
Jack: Yeah!
*crowd cheers*
Wade: I think that's a yes
*crowd laughs*
Jack: Congratulations
Jack: Happy for you
Jack: You old dog!
*crowd cheers*
Wade: This floor got really wobbly all of a sudden
*Mark laughs*
Bob: Yeah, you okay?
Wade: I'm good!
Mark: you alright?
Wade: I got something in my eye
*Bob laughs*
Mark: Yeah, so-
Mark: We- We didn't know how to continue the panel because-
Mark: If it was seemed weird cause
Mark: I came out here and I was nervous
Mark: and I've never been nervous at one of my own panels before
Mark: That's why!
Mark: cause I was like "oh my god, I don't know how to-"
Wade: I was perfectly fine and ready
Wade: and backstage everyone's like
Wade (high pitched): "oh my god I'm so nervous!"
*Bob laughs*
Wade: and I was like- "Please Stop!"
Wade: So I was thinking we'd do this at the end
Wade: And Mark's like "let's do it at the beginning" and so...
Wade: Well, where do we go from here
Mark: I wanted to start on a high note
Mark: and then let it crash and burn!
*laughter*
Mark: That's not an analogy for anything else
Mark: That's just I'm talking about me, me alone!
*Bob laughs*
Mark: That's me! That's me
Jack: See, this is what he was afraid of
Mark: That I'm gonna ruin everything
Mark: with my big fat mouth
Jack: the precedent would be ruined
*someone from the crowd says something*
Mark: What?
*crowd laughs*
*someone has loud hyena laughter*
Bob: Woah
Mark: I remember that laugh
Jack: Your biggest fan right there
*laughter*
Mark: oh yeah but anyway
Mark: so now we can actually calm down and maybe have a seat cause
Wade: Yeah that sounds great
Mark: My knees are wobbly
Bob: Was that hard for you Mark?
Mark: I was trying not to cry
Mark: I really was
Wade:It's okay buddy
*Mark and Wade laugh*
Mark: I'm so happy, I'm the happiest I've ever been
Mark: The best day of my life
Wade: I- I though about this for like, a long time
Wade: and I, I though of all these different ideast I would do
Wade: and it's like-
Wade: everything about the way our relationship started revolved around uh,
Wade: Us, doing stupid stuff, and people laughing out of pity.
Wade: So I figured,
*laughter*
Mark: mostly at me
Wade: I figured, another video felt to similar to the
Wade: the original proposal to ask her out
Mark: Yeah
Wade: So
Wade: I figured it had to be a panel
Wade:So that's why we ended up here
Mark: Well I'm honoured, that on, m- the Markiplier panel
*laughter*
Mark: and Friend
Bob: oh cool thanks yeah
Mark: I said friend, not friends,
Mark: and Friend
Wade: I got an upgrade!
*Mark and Wade laugh*
Mark: You're now, Primary Friend
Mark: Secondary and Tertiary Friend (points to Bob and Jack)
*crowd awws*
Mark: Se- Nah
Jack: I, I came, I came late to the game
Jack: so I'm okay
Mark: Yeah, technically I- i-
Mark: This is the order that I knew you guys
Jack: yeah
Mark: So you first, you second, you third.
Mark: or last.
Wade: We didn't plan that out at all actually that's-
Jack: I'm- I'm the last friend you're gonna make
Mark: The last friend I'll ever- no other friend will want-
Bob: secretly hierarchical amongst us,
Wade: Whenever we give up on him we *unintelligible*
*Bob and Jack laugh*
Mark: Thanks man
Wade: you're welcome friend
Mark: This panel's so,
Bob: The happy-
Mark: Just a rollercoaster of emotions
Bob: The happiest day of your life Mark
Mark (cry/laughing?): Thanks man
Mark: Yeah, but anyway we literally don't know how to continue the panel so
Mark: give us a moment to uh, collect ourselves as we uh
Mark: think on,
Wade: what do we normally do to get revved up
Mark: all my mistakes
Wade: we normally just talk about penises, or something
Mark: I don't feel like that'd be appropriate at this panel anymore
Wade: No? I don't...
Bob: Wade you can talk about whatever you want
Wade: No, don't put this on- I've done enough talking
Bob: go, go crazy
Mark: yeah
Wade: My throat's still very dry I'm gonna drink some more
Mark: Jack?
Wade: I had a lot more words by the way but they just kinda left
Mark: you got anything to say?
Jack: Sh- it's cool being here
Jack: I love it. It's awesome
*crowd laughs*
Mark: Thanks man
Wade: Improv, (unintelligible)
Jack: Wait, did you have any idea he was gonna do that?
Mark: Yeah, it was so hard to keep it a secret
Mark (laughing): cause you were always next to him
*laughter*
Wade: Yeah, I actually agree,
Wade: So the other day we went looking uh
Wade: for a new flannel for this guy
Wade: and uh, I took the opportunity to go with
Wade: so i could actually divulge this plan
Mark: yeah
Wade: and the whole time Molly's texting
Wade (grouchy voice): "Where are you hurry up and come back"
Wade: I'm like "If only you knew what I was trying to set in motion"
*others laugh*
Wade: I need this time away give me a break
Jack: Great start to the proposal there
Wade: It's a great start to the relation-
Wade (grouchy voice): I need a break, ah, leave me alone
*Mark and Bob laugh*
Wade: I'm trying to figure out how to propose to you darn it
Mark: Well anyway yeah, I guess we could just
Mark: reminisce or... We'll open up to questions eventually
Mark: we got Cory and Brandon somewhere
Mark: they got, they got, oh, there they are, yeah
Mark: eventually we've got microphones here so we're not gonna do the lineup thing
Mark: because it gets crazy there's too many people it'd be a mad dash so,
Mark: So we're gonna do questions later but not now, so don't waste your arms,
*crowd laughs*
Jack: Who're you?
Mark: did anyone else see that?
Bob: that's my ear guy
Wade: Did you know he was
Bob: yeah
Wade: did he just come out and start touching
Bob: I- I pay him to stay back there and do that
Bob: He, he keeps a distance, but he follows me everywhere in case of
Mark: I gotta-
Bob: ear stuff
Mark: that's nice
Bob: yeah
Wade: That was more unexpected that the proposal I think
Wade: everyone was laughing and I turned around and there was just
(unintelligible)
Mark: I though I was funny for a moment there and then it was just like
Mark: Oh no, not me. Okay. I see.
Wade:That's kinda like yesterday during the signing when everyone-
Wade: You held up the Purell as I was taking a selfie
Mark: yeah
Wade: you thought everyone was cheering your hand sanitizer
Mark: Well I didn't think-
*Wade laughs*
Mark: I- this is sounds insulting again because everything I sounds insulting but
Mark: like, I didn't think my fans were stupid
Mark: that they would cheer Purell and I'm like
Mark: But there they're going! and I'm like Oh Okay
Mark: But it wasn't true you guys are not stupid that's not what I think
*laughter (especially Wade's)*
Mark: Save Me!
Mark: Help me, I'm Dying
Jack: nailed it
Mark: Help me
Bob: you're doing such a good job though
Wade: does anybody want the Friend part I think I need to trade
*Bob and Wade laugh*
Wade: This ship is sinking fast
Bob: This is- Well this is what it always devolves into though
Wade: that's true
Bob: Cause whenever we get out here immediately I think back to like
Bob: the first time I was on a panel
Bob: Cause the first couple were just you guys
Bob: and the first time I came was like PAX south
Bob: and that panel room, I remember I walked in and I was like
Bob: "oh man look at this big room"
Bob: and like it was a big room but it was like
Bob: what, 400 seats or something?
Bob: Like it was, it was like a panel room, it was not a theatre
Bob: with lights, and the monitor speaker like,
Bob: every time we do this it's always like
Mark: a little bigger
Bob: Is this where they meant to put us?
* Jack, Wade, and Mark, laugh*
Bob: this-
Mark: did they make a horrible error?
Bob: yeah
*laughter*
Bob: was there just like an open spot and they were like
Bob (derpy voice): "Well bump this one" like-
Bob: but no and you guys always come out which is so cool!
Mark + Wade: Yeah
Bob: and we all got to experience Wade and Molly's,
Bob: big moment together and that's cool
Bob: but there have been so many good moments with you guys
*crowd cheers
Mark: I mean, I mean, each time we come out here it's a little
Mark: it's a little, it's like a little landmark in
Mark: life, uh, not trying to be too profound but like
Mark: because every day is just like "Oh, get up and make videos" but,
Mark: you know when we come out to an event like this
Mark: and we actually get to see you face to face like that,
Mark: that like, really means something to know
Mark: in perspective of how many people are actually out there
Mark: and want to waste their time on us
*laughter*
Mark: and, it's it's really an honour that you guys come out for this
Mark: and ah I'm so, like grateful,
Mark: that you guys have been here since the beginning because
Mark: even at the first panel, it was still, pretty packed in there
Wade: yeah it was. I think, I don't remember the size of the room but it was
Wade: pretty full all the way back
Mark: it was dang huge an- an- so,
Mark: it it's just, y'know
Mark: it's overwhelming sometimes to think about
Mark: how far, like, we've come and
Mark: and Jack just hit 12 million over there you just hit 1 million,
*crowd cheers*
Mark: Bob what are you at!
Bob: I just hit- I hit half a million
Mark: Yeah! Nice man!
Jack: Yeah!
Wade: Half a million!
Bob: almost a whole number!
Mark: yeah!
Bob: I'm almost on the same scale as you guys...
Mark: well you were doing law school, so you can't exactly say that,
Mark: like, you were able to do it full-time
Bob: that's true.
*Jack + Mark laugh*
Bob: I had forgot about law school
*laughter*
Jack (sassy): thanks!
Wade: you also got a degree so you can have a job in 5 years unlike the rest of us
Mark: yeah true
Jack: I have a degree!
Mark: yeah you've got a degree in hotel management!
Wade: I got a philosophy degree-
Jack: It's useless, but it's there!
Wade: I can ponder! professionally
Mark (laughing): you could philosophize...
Jack: you Could have been an engineer
Mark: I could have.
Bob: people clamoring
Bob: to pay you to think about stuff
Wade: yeah, people'd just pay me to think for them
Wade: and then I don't have to give them real answers cause philosophy never has any
Mark: nice
Bob: it's perfect
Mark: yeah good job
Mark: so all you philosophy majors he's making fun of you
Mark: very sorry about that
Wade: Wasnos (?)
Mark: any engineering majors out there?
Mark: yeah!
Jack: six people
Mark: there's dozens of us!
Mark: Dozens!
*laughter*
Mark: yeah. alright, so uh,
Mark: any other profound things you guys have?
Bob: never
Mark: never?
Jack: never
Mark: Never at all? ok
Wade: I've used up all my profound juices for today
Mark: I think- I think I've finally recovered
Mark: like, god my heart was racing
Mark: well you wouldn't believe I've- I literally
Mark: When I say I've never been nervous coming out to a panel it's because I know it's gonna be crap
Mark: and it's like whatever happens happens
Mark: But this like, the stakes were actually high like,
Mark: I cannot mess this up I have to do this right
Mark: I have to do this. For you.
Wade: Your nervousness helped me a lot
Mark: so uh-
Wade: Jack was like "aahh"
Wade: Mark was "engh"
Wade: Bob was "enh enh enh enh"
Mark: Jack was rubbing his nipples out of nervousness behind the stage
Bob: What?
Mark: That's a weird nervous tick to be honest
*Jack laughs*
Jack: I can't help it man *laughs*
Mark: Like literally I look over and he's like
Mark: "I'm so nervous I can't-"
*laughter*
Mark: "I can't help it man!"
Jack: at least my shirt was on okay
Wade: at first
Mark: that's the second stage
Bob: well what I was wondering to know is were you making the squeaking sounds or does that just happen
*mark laughing*
Jack: it was a dry day okay
*laughter*
Mark: ok, so, we'll now open it up to questions so
Mark: Cory and Brandon will be coming around
Jack: woo!
Mark: One will be in one aisle, one will be in the other,
Mark: we'll pick you out, We'll give a-
Bob: you don't have to duck Brandon they can still see you
*Jack and Wade laugh*
Mark: That's Brandon. That's Cory.
Jack: He has terrible jokes
Mark: Clap for them dang it!
*crowd cheers*
Mark: Alright. So if you have a question, raise your hand,
Mark: Be very peaceful about it, don't hold up, small children, things like that, don't do that.
Mark: alright. Uh, who first.
Mark: alright, how about, you're right up front so why not
Questionner: Uh, ok, Yesterday I had to hold a mic so
Questionner: Um so I came to your panel last year
Questtioner: I don't know if you remember me but I gave you the little bag with the tiny dice.
*crowd laughs*
Questionner: I was squeaky
Mark: Was it a small pack of dice?
Mark: multiple dice?
Questionner: yeah no
Questionner: It was a little cube with three little tiny dice in it
Questionner: with a pink moustache on the bag?
Mark (whispers): my goodness
*crowd laughs*
Questionner: yeah
Mark (whispers): I don't remember
Questionner: I...
*Mark chuckles*
Mark (laughing): I don't wanna lie!
Jack: I have no idea what's happening
Questionner: It's ok...
Mark: Yeah. I- I'm sure it's somehwere. I- I promise...
Questionner: I've always been, I used to wondered if...
Questionner: If you still kept it
Mark: Help me!
Mark: Don't leave me! Help me! Please!
*Jack, Wade, and especially Bob laugh*
Mark: ok, thanks friends
Bob: it's not- It's not his fault
Mark: yes
Questionner: So, um.
Questionner: I made a Wilford Warfstache jacket in your honour this year
Mark:I see that
Questionner: Um
Mark:It's lovely
Questionner: Thank you! It doesn't close, because Wilford Warfstache doesn't have boobs
Wade: Neither does his when he's alone
Questionner: So...
Wade: or he thinks he's alone
Mark: What does that mean? Hang on a sec
Wade: Remember the uh, picture
Mark: Explain yourself
Wade: Remember the picture you sent us, the other day
Mark: oh, the naked pictures that I always send you every morning.
*crowd laughs*
Wade:I was referring to the-
Mark: that's not a joke, I literally did. But anyways
Wade: We call the most recent outfit the uh, 'The crusty leapord'
Mark: oh yeah, oh, you remember that,
Mark: I posted on insta- Sorry we'll get to you in just a second
Mark: Remember that picture I posted on instagram, of uh,
Mark: The leapord, uh robe?
Mark: That- That robe was mysteriously in my apartment,
Mark: There's another picture that I sent to them that was a bit more spread
Wade: yeah
Mark: That was for them only
Jack: it was not good
Mark: anyway yes, now I
Wade: That was our wake up image
Questionner: so I, I wanted to ask, how
Questionner: Like how did you adjust from moving from Cincinnati all the way out to LA
Questionner: to do what you wanted to do, like-
Mark: Oh, it was horrible
Questionner: I was, cons, cause I have been considering moving to LA specifically
Questionner: So what's it like
Mark (slowly): What for?
Mark: Cause you gotta think about that
Questionner: like, probably youtube? movie... stuff, acting
Mark: You don't need to go- If movies, like-
Mark: I don't even think you need to go to LA for movies anymore because,
Mark: uh, the thing about youtube and doing youtube is like, it's independent
Mark: So, there's a lot of avenues for doing independent stuff now
Mark: like, phone cameras are almost as good as like
Mark: traditional cameras were 10 years ago like,
Mark: it's amazing the jump in technology and what you can do cause
Mark: One, LA's expensive
Mark: Two LA's hot, it's dirty, it's stanky, the people suck, it's awful
Questionner: You don't make a good case for it
Mark: What?
Mark: I mean, where are you from originally?
Questionner: Here. Ah, well, north of here
Mark: Oh well this place is lovely
Bob: why would you leave here?
Jack: Seattle's great
Questionner: it's yeah, I, I was actually gonna say so you should move to Seattle then
Questionner: because if LA sucks...
Mark: nah, i'm not gonna do that
*crowd cheers*
Mark: It's not that lovely
Wade: Stop trying to take him I'm still trying to get him back to Cincinnati
Questionner: Well, go a little bit north...
Bob: Mark, you need to move back to Cincinnati,
Mark: I will eventually. Yeah. yeah Jack move to Cincinnati
Bob: yeah
Bob: yeah, come on Jack
Jack: No!
*Mark laughs*
Mark: what?
Questionner: Go a little bit north, like about an hour north of here it's a little place called Bellingham and it's amazing
*crowd cheers*
Questionner: yeah!
Mark: Bellingham in the house!
Wade: apparently
Mark: Anyway, uh, you just gotta think about what you're leaving behind, first and foremost
Mark: cause I had to like, leave behind friends and family
Mark: and I mean, when I went out to LA at first I was regretful
Mark: but then you know, I had more opportunities out there,
Mark: like I had a lot more work opportunities, like social network stuff,
Mark: like I met a lot of people, but I still miss my family!
Mark: so it's, it's it's definitely a sacrifice, to go away from your family like,
Mark: I think it was worth it for me, but you really gotta, it's a personal choice so,
Mark: I can't decide for you
Wade: I- I mean,
Wade: I've though about moving out to LA a few times, I still live in Cincinnati,
Wade: and it just hasn't seemed like it's been the right time or the right reason
Wade: I mean, I just crossed a million subscribers on youtube and things are going pretty well
Wade:and I'm very content staying in Cincinnati, unless there's a big reason to come out to LA,
Wade: It's just too much money, too much craziness, to leave the place that I think of as home
Bob: and this isn't exactly, an answer to your specific question but,
Bob: Many and I moved to North Carolina from Cincinnati,
Bob: which is a pretty far- almost as far a move- almost
Bob: because we had to go- we were going to grad school and that was where we had to go
Bob: to go to the schools that we wanted to go to
Bob: So like, we had no choice, that was the place where the schools were,
Bob: and, for us, it's still been, awful.
Bob: the place is very nice, the weather's nice,
Bob: school has been, a good experience, and, and we're glad we did grad school
Bob: but we are so miserable being that far away from family
Bob: and we left all our friends behind in Cincinnati,
Bob: it's absolutely personal. Cause we cannot wait,
Bob:to get, get outta North Carolina, get to Ohio,
Bob: and so we can be around our people again, so
Bob: it depends very heavily, how you feel, about that sort of stuff
Wade (quietly): yeah, everyone left me
*crowd laughs*
Questionner: Jack, Jack do you ever think about moving to America?
Jack: I dunno
*crowd cheers*
Bob: Cincinnati Jack! Cincinnati.
Jack: Everyone keeps saying, it's like "move to LA"
Jack: but like, I was I was there
Mark: Don't move to LA
Jack: I was there for like a week, that was, that was good
Mark: yeah don't do that, yeah
Jack: I almost, I'm almost like combusted while I was there
Jack: like this white skin cannot last out there
*laughter*
Questionner: I told you this last year and I said move to Seattle, it's better
*crowd cheers*
Mark: don't do that either
Jack: I mean...
Mark: Cincinnati's great
Mark: very cheap. It's so cheap man
Wade: Cincinnati
Jack: I mean, if I'm gonna move to America, it would be for youtube stuff,
Jack: and like, LA is the place to go for that
Bob: for now
Jack:  LA, San Fransisco, or New York
Mark: New York yeah also
Jack: umm
Jack: New York was not nice, that place is, that was just way too many people
Jack: that was just a sensory overload being there, so
Mark: Compared to the hills of Ireland I bet like New York is just not okay
Jack: Yeah. Plus, Ireland is quaint, nobody can find me over there
Jack: It's easy, it's simple. We have sheep.
*laughter*
Questionner: Well at least if you move here you'll blend in with the pale white skin, y'know
Jack: You make a compelling case, I'll think about it
Questionner: and you won't get burnt, cause there's not that much sun
Jack: That's true! It's felt like right at home here
Questionner: yeah
Jack: Just been raining all the time
Jack: so why would I come and not just stay at home? *laughs*
Wade: I just think be sure, be 100% sure you want to move before you do
Wade: cause it's hard
Jack: Yeah, cause, cause when you moved like
Jack: You already had like stability, like on youtube
Mark: yeah
Jack: it was already working out so moving like,
Jack: there wasn't like, a whole lot to lose,
Jack: it was obviously going to continue
Mark: It was a logical step for me
Jack: yeah, so I wouldn't go there and then start youtube out there,
Jack: because that is a cruel environment to be in
Mark: oh no, no no no, don't do that
Mark: yeah, but anyway, hope that answered your question
Questionner: Thank you
Mark: Thank you
Jack: we just crushed her spirit
Mark: I will look for the dice
*crowd laughs*
Mark: I promise
Mark: what about someone
Bob: what about this side of the theatre!
Mark: yeah, over there
Questionner: I have this-
Jack: There's a dude with two hands up back there waving
Bob: yeah there's a dude waving both of his hands
Jack: Wacky waving inflatable arm flailing tube man!
Bob: no, def-
Mark: down with the red hair?
Mark: red hair? yeah
Someone: I'll flag him down I'll flag him down
Questionner: Okay now I'm going blank *laughs*
Mark: hello
Questionner: um..
Questionner: It's funny cause like...
Mark: What's your name?
Questionner: Tyler!
Mark (drawn out): Hi Tyler
everyone: Hi Tyler
Tyler: Hi, other red head
*Jack laughs*
Tyler: Um, ok I'm going blank cause right now before we begin here
Tyler: uh, I was thinking about giving, you a banana for some reason
Tyler: and then she reminded me about your girlfriend so I was thinking about kimshe
Tyler: You! Doritos I don't know what you want Bob
Tyler: because I don't know what you eat or what you do
Mark: did you catch any of that?
Bob: I'm not sure what's happening
Tyler: In terms of food! it's nothing... I know you- but... um...
Wade: We can't hear you very well up here
Jack: Yeah I can't hear anything
Mark: No I can hear him fine!
Mark: I can't understand him!
*laughter*
Mark: I am-
Tyler: should I come closer?
Mark: All of my brain power is trying to listen to you, I swear
Tyler: Should I come closer
Mark: Doesn't matter!
Mark: You're on a microphone
Jack: yell it
Mark: try it.. uh yeah
Jack: It's too echo-y in here
Mark: you're good at the Irish mumbling right?
Mark: decipher that
Mark (squaking): wha-da-the- that's what he was doing before
Wade: yeah
Mark: do the Irish mumbling that you were talking about
Tyler: mumbling?
Jack: *says something Irish*
Mark: yeah see that
*crowd cheers*
Mark: that wasn't even Irish
Wade: I think he just ordered two scoops of buttered pecan
Mark: Ok, alright.
Tyler: Big question or small question; Big question is um
Tyler: How do you decide on your charity, uh
Tyler: where you donate for you charities
Mark:oh!
Tyler: Uh, I just need it for me like
Tyler: Uh it's been about
Tyler: an anniversary for one of our friends that we've lost for
Tyler: x y and z and-
Tyler: for me I want to do my own uh live stream, for her
Tyler: for her friend's cause, I just
Tyler: don't know, where to start. I know,
Tyler: I doubt myself the equipment
Tyler: and I doubt which charity to go to, so
Tyler: I want to do one but I don't know where to start
Mark: uh Charity's a personal thing most of the time
Mark: I mean with me it's like I take suggestions from you guys
Mark: I- I look at like, Charity Navigator I try to find like a reputable charity
Mark: you know not just like a popular charity
Mark: I try to find smaller causes, big causes because,
Mark: You'd be amazed, at the difference that like,
Mark: We just did for Musaid, and we raised uh, over 60 thousand dollars for Musaid
Mark: and, to them, that was world changing. Like,
Mark: (stutters) what did- what could they do with that money
Bob: Yeah well I mean, so, the-
Bob: I don't have any specifics from them
Bob: But it- Musaid's a really small organization
Bob: It's like a few friends from college who were music-
Bob: Musicians and music teachers, who just like,
Bob: decided they wanted to teach music in other countries,
Bob: So what they usually do is they buy instruments
Bob: and they send teachers, into other countries to like,
Bob: teach students, and teach teachers how to teach their students,
Bob: and they- Last year Mandy and I did a thing,
Bob: where it's just us, and we raised a few thousand dollars?
Bob: and they- and Kevin sent us a message and was like
Bob: It had a huge impact and allowed them, to do a lot more stuff
Bob: So this year we raised, 60 thousand dollars,
Bob: that's potentially-
*crowd cheers*
Bob: That's potentially an entire new country they could go to,
Bob: an entire new program, or several new people that they could send overseas to do more teaching
Bob: I mean 60 thousand dollars worth of musical instruments,
Bob: If you're buying student grade instruments is-
Bob: like an entire band, potentially, if you purchase smartly, like,
Bob: that- that is, more money probably than they
Bob: than they had fundraised for them last year because they're such a small group
Bob: so they're gonna do tons of stuff, lots more kids and people and
Bob: in these other countries they're working with
Bob: are gonna get, uh, are gonna be affected by that
Bob: Whereas if we raised that much money for like, American Red Cross,
Bob: it's still a good cause, but the American Red Cross would like,
Bob: send you a letter that was like "Thank you very much Mark Fischbach"
Bob: "For raising such a great amount of money for us. We'll definitely put it to good use"
Bob: and then, like, it goes off into the Ether
Bob: but we're gonna get, Kevin has said he's gonna send us pictures and stories
Bob: and we're gonna get to see, all these kids that,
Bob: the money that we raised is specifically going to help
Bob: that had- you know, they, they just didn't have the resources to help them
Bob: and so we did that so it's-
Bob: That's why small charities are so cool, the impact you get to see from it
Mark: There's definitely a wealth of options out there
Mark: oh thank you. Two people, that's great
Mark: There's definitely a wealth of options out there so,
Mark: The first and foremost is like a cause that resonates with you,
Mark: and obviously cause our musical background like we really
Mark: like that, I mean, Jack plays the drums, like, You play any instruments?
Bob: ah just keep going
Mark: Yeah anyway so, yeah but
Jack: No time for a joke
Mark: Find some cause that's personal to you
Mark: and then, looking at the impact that it can make.
Mark: I'm not saying there's anything bad about the bigger charities,
Mark: but, there's often time small charities that are trying to get off the ground
Mark: for these smaller causes that don't affect as many people that need just as much help
Mark: but, if you don't think you can raise like 60 thousand like we can,
Mark: last year they raised, a couple thousand,
Mark: and that made a huge difference,
Mark: that made the world's difference to that charity organization
Mark: so you can make a huge impact, you just have to pick something that,
Mark: is really close to home for you.
*crowd cheers*
Tyler: at the same time I'm also really scared for that as well
Tyler: cause on top of choosing the charity I think I'm just
Tyler: against the wall with equipment because I-
Tyler: know the cause I wanna go towards  and I have an idea for it,
Tyler: it's just I don't- I doubt my delivery because of
Tyler: um lack of funding and personal funding cause that's just kind of, put me on edge, so
Mark: Do you have a phone?
Tyler: Yes
Mark: Do you have a, smartphone?
Tyler: yes
Mark: You can live stream on that. That's all it takes
Mark: Like literally that's all it take nowadays
Mark: You can do anything, just- you just gotta start small
Mark: as small as you can
*crowd cheers*
Mark: So, the only thing limiting is just, like, what you have
Mark: it won't be as good as if we had like, our computer setup and multiple microphones
Mark: but, if you just wanna turn that phone on for 24 hours straight
Mark: like tell people about a cause like,
Mark: that's a start, that's starting somewhere. yeah.
Tyler: I was thinking about, ghost pepper jelly, um, games and dying on the camera, but yeah.
Mark: What?
*crowd laughs*
Tyler: uh, Don't know where this is going now cause I'm so- uh,
Tyler: yeah
Jack: Thank you!
Mark (laughing): okay thank you
*crowd cheers*
Wade: it echo's, it's really hard to hear
Mark: yeah
Mark: alright
Jack: it's super echo-y in here it's so hard to hear anything
Mark: who picked last time?
Bob: I think we should go way the crap in the back
Mark: yeah. go, run, run!
Bob: bye Brandon sorry
Mark: Brandon run!
Bob: don't don't hurt yourself
Jack: get those steps Brandon
Mark: Run!
Bob: There's, there's-
Mark: Pick!
Mark: Pick for us
Mark: Be independent
Mark: yeah okay
Brandon: He's got a mask
Brandon: and a bat, I'm scared
Mark (breathy voice): It's from off
Mark (breathy voice): or maybe he's from Undertale I don't know
Questionner: Hi guys
Mark: hello
Jack: hi
Questionner:  Mark, Wade, Bob, Jack, all you guys are beautiful
Questionner:  anyway, um, Mark?
Questionner: This is for you two things
Questionner: One, I was there, at your very first panel
Questionner: and honestly that was amazing
Mark: oh cool!
Questionner: um, I gave you a band-aid that you put on your head
Questionner: that uh apparently a lot of people
Mark: oh yeah
Mark: cause I uh, I banged my head
Questionner: yeah, cause you signed my Death Note
Questionner: I am incredibly sorry a lot of you guys can actually blame me for that
Questionner: um and Two,
Questionner: While I was at the panel a question really did catch my attention
Questionner: and I have been honestly waiting for it for a while
Questionner: are you still going to be doing your Occulus Rift of Vanish
Mark: No. No!
*laughter*
Mark: No!
Jack: Occulus Rift What?
Questionner: Vanish
Mark: Occulus Rift Vanish no!
Jack (laughing): oh
Mark: No! Why would I?
Mark: I beat that game. Totally legitimately
(something from the crowd)
Mark: I know I did!
Mark: I was there! I beat it.
Questionner (quietly): you said you were gonna do it, like-
Mark: I- I- I've changed. Markiplier has changed, I'm a liar
Mark: Not the same as I used to be. No- eh- No.
Wade: Once again, does anybody else want to be the Friend?
Mark: no.
Questionner: Bob Wade, uh Jack can you guys,
Questionner: help me out here, kinda convince him, cause...
Jack: no!
Wade: You think in the four years
Jack: I have no sway!
Wade: we've been doing this he's listened to us once?
*Mark laughs*
Mark: No! Maybe.
Mark: Maybe! No. maybe I don't know
Questionner (dragged out): Please?
Mark: No!
Questionner: aww
*laughter*
Mark (laughing): Thank you
*laugher*
Mark (laughing): Thank you for your que- Thank you for being here for two years staight
Mark: or three years straight now. Three?
Mark: Three years? Yeah three years straight. Thank you so much
Mark: yeah. ok.
Bob: Jack you pick one
Jack: Uh, Cory you love running right?
Cory (very quietly): yeah I love it
Jack: Ok. Um,
Jack: ugh, I can't see
Jack: A- a lady just stood up with a phone
Wade: Whelp, now we've encouraged a whole new way of raising your hand
Jack (quietly): shit
Mark: You could just pass the mic down that would've been easier
Mark: ah it's fine. Hello.
Questionner: Hi!
Mark: What's your name
Questionner: Julianne
Mark: Hi Julianne
Everyone: Hi Julianne
Wade: Is it only the people on the right that we've done that for so far?
Mark: Yeah, I- I don't know why, I'm biased.
Julianne: So I know you guys have a lot of um subscribers on youtube,
Julianne: And you guys have had really great journeys,
Julianne: Each of you individually
Julianne: And I wanted to know if you guys kind of had
Julianne: like, a Beyonce moment? Where you felt like,
Julianne: "I feel like I might be kind of a big deal"
*laughter*
Wade: Just now
Bob: Is that a thing that Beyonce's known for?
Wade: I don't know
Mark: I don't think so, yeah
Wade: Maybe that's J-Lo I'm thinking of
Mark: yeah J-Lo, Kim Kardashian,
Mark: Nicki Minaj...
Wade: Nope! I'm wrong, no Beyonce moment yet
Mark: Bob, Jack? You wanna take this first?
Jack: uh, I don't know, it- it was weird because it was-
Jack: It- it all happened like so fast, so I didn't have like any time to catch up to anything,
Jack: Or like, like sit back and go "Wow, this actually happened!"
Jack: It kinda just took off on it's own
Jack: but I think it was the time like,
Jack: When- I think it was when you and Felix both followed me,
Jack: within like the space of three days,
Mark: Oh yeah
Jack: I was like "Holy shit"
Jack: "That's so cool!"
Jack: I mean now I can't stand you, but
Mark: yeah I know right
*laughter*
Jack: No, I mean, there was no point where I sat back and I was like,
Jack: "Yeah I'm hot shit"
*laughter*
Jack: It- It was a case of like realizing that the channel was like,
Jack: bigger than me,
Jack: because before it was just like
Jack: Me, in a cabin, sitting down and making videos
Jack: and then when I realized, a lot of people were watching them
Jack: I was like "Uh oh, I- I have to be, responsible now"
*laughter*
Jack: So, I don't know, I can't pin point the exact like,
Jack: day, or anything that happened but, it was definitely like,
Jack: the end of 2014 or something like that, I think
Bob: For me it happens a lot, uh
*laughter*
Mark: "I'm Beyonce everyday"
Jack: You always think you're hot shit
Bob: I mean, well not- it's more, it's more like, I'm suprised.
Bob: But it's- everytime-
Bob: Like even at this PAX still like
Bob: we come out and we do stuff like this
Bob: or I'm on the- I was on the floor during like media hour
Bob: and I was like "man I wanna talk to some of these guys" and
Bob: when you walk up t- to a booth where it's like an indie dev's
Bob: and they're just trying to talk about their game and they're like
Bob: "Oh yeah I've seen your channel, yeah come look"
Bob: and they say hi and it's like
Bob: But I wanted to talk to- You know me?
Bob: I wanted to talk-
*Laughter*
Bob: It's so weird Why do you know me
Bob: That's hi- Like it's still almost creepy for me
Bob: Cause I just don't feel like- but you know and obviously
Bob: I know you and some people are aware of me but
Bob: every time that happens I get that moment where it's like
Bob: Woah shit
*laughter*
Wade: I don't know if it's ever hit me hit me,
Wade: I mean, when I hit half a million subscribers
Wade: like 500 thousand was like, the most impactful milestone I hit
Wade: at far as like, emotionally,
Wade: I was just balling my eyes out for like 20 minutes
Wade: I was like "I did it"
Wade: and like "my fans are great"
Wade: I don't know, I don't know why that number it just felt like
Wade: Y'know kinda it was kind of a grind to get there I mean,
Wade: Y'know obviously we're with Mark, and Jack and things and like
Wade: You see your friends booming and stuff
Wade: And I've never been in a hurry to get anywhere
Wade: I've been very happy with my growth,
Wade: but hitting that milestone it just felt like an accomplishment it's like
Wade: I posted a lot of videos, and we hit a number that was so astronomical
Wade: because when Mark with 20 thousand subscribers,
Wade: uh Bob and I and a bunch of his mods and fans
Wade: put together a congratulations video
Wade: and whenever he hit that it was like,
Wade: from, a friend perspective, I was like
Wade: "It doesn't get any bigger than this
*laughter*
Wade: like, "Mark is big time now, 20 thousand people"
Wade: and then, the numbers we think about now are just so astronomical that it's hard to even imagine
Wade: So, I don't feel any different than I think I did day one,
Wade: But, there are certain moments that we have that's like,
Wade: Why are so many people here
*laughter*
Wade: Cause I don't find- I hired an editor because I don't find myself funny
Wade: I couldn't even edit my own content I thought it was so bad
Jack: Poor Day
Wade: I know!
Jack: poor Day
Wade: She quits every convention I have to re-hire her
Bob: It happened like before the convention even started this time
Wade: I know!
Bob: The first morning we were here it was like
Bob: I can't, I can't
Wade: Mark you were born feeling like Beyonce weren't you?
Mark: yeah pretty much
*laughter*
Mark: burst out of the womb, very excited
Mark: No ah my- my  Beyonce moo-ment was
Mark: "moo-ment" was uh, very early on
Mark: uh, it was the first Comicon I ever went to
Mark: I- I- I didn't know, if anybody actually knew me there like,
Mark: This was really early, like when I only had less than 2000 subscribers,
Mark: uh when I was first at Comicon, and
Mark: like I posted on Facebook like "I'm going to Comicon ooh!"
Mark: and like 12 liked it I'm like
Mark (goofy voice): "Oh oh oh oh, yes, yeah! 12 people!"
Mark: Statistically improbably that anybody is at Comicon
Mark: but then, like, I- I- I was wandering around the floor there, and
Mark: there was, I believe, four people
Mark: at Comicon that actually came up and recognized me, and said hi to me,
Mark: and I've never, ever, had the same feeling, as that-
Mark: for- previously in my life, cause I was a very, like,
Mark: quiet kid, I was very quiet guy, no one ever like practically came up to me because
Mark: Why- why would they have a reason to so,
Mark: the fact that people, both came up to me,
Mark: told me that they enjoyed what I made,
Mark: It was mind-blowing to me, it was earth-shattering
Mark: and that's like, that was the convention that I came back
Mark: and I realized, that I had to do something
Mark: like good with this channel, that's when I realized I had to start doing charity live streams
Mark: like it was that moment, where I'm like
Mark: "oh my god, there's real people that are really really watching me"
Mark: "and really care about what I do and what I say, I have to be careful about this"
Mark: and you know, I- I- I really wanted to protect it
Mark: and like, from that one moment, like, it spawned everything
Mark: cause, without that I- I- I doubt I would have felt the same way about youtube
Mark: I committed my life like at that moment, to doing this
Mark: Forever. So...
Wade: and then you changed
Mark: and then I changed I've changed since then yeah I'm I'm much different
Jack: Now he doesn't give a shit at all
Mark: I'm terrible now yeah
Mark: So, yeah no that was my Beyonce moment
Jack: Thank you
*crowd cheers*
Wade: There's Brandon
Mark: There's Brandon
*something shouted from the crowd followed by laughter*
Mark: No!
Bob: We're not doing that side
Mark: Oh that's a bomb Symmetra cosplay there
Mark: There's a Symmetra, right there
Bob: Oh that is pretty awesome
Jack: That's awesome
Wade: Careful watch out for turrets
Mark: She's deadly up close
Mark: people always underestimate her
Jack: the pathway is open, run
Questionner: oh, hold on if you hold it? ok, hi!
Mark, Wade, Jack: hi
Wade: What's your name
Questionner: My name is-
Questionner: I'm Yoshi
Mark: Yoshi?
Yoshi: Yoshi.
Mark + some: Hi Yoshi
Wade: Yay, we finally acknowledge the left
Yoshi: yes thank you we were we were all like "if you go over here could we get the hi thing too?"
Yoshi: alright. So, um... so...
Yoshi: I missed you guys last year because I was trying to get tickets
Yoshi: and, I just, I couldn't do it, and I got really sad, because I was like
Yoshi: "not gonna see Markiplier and his friends"
Yoshi: and I got
Mark: and my friends
Yoshi: friends
Mark: my friends
Bob: thank you for including us
Yoshi: and I got, I got like, um i was like
Wade: well, Friend.
Yoshi: really sad about it and stuff so I was like "ok, I'm gonna go next year"
Yoshi: and I finally got my tickets this year
Yoshi: and, I was, Yes, I was super excited
Yoshi: so I'm like "yes, i'm gonna see him"
Yoshi: and I had this plan, like, I was like,
Yoshi: Ok. When I go to the signing, or if I meet you guys,
Yoshi: cause I heard you guys just walk around and people meet you all the time
Yoshi: So I was like "If I ever meet them, I'm gonna give them the whole story,"
Yoshi: the whole, like, you know the, those memes that it's like
Yoshi: "this band saved my life"? I'm that meme
Yoshi: you guys saved my life
Yoshi: But um, I- yeah I'm that meme, but I'm like,
Yoshi: the- the whole, "you guys, oh, you- you got me through a rough time" all that
Yoshi: I'm like "oh I'm sure they hear that a lot they're not really gonna care" but then,
Yoshi: I thought about it, you guys are, y'all- y'all are just like, all really caring people
Yoshi: so I know you guys care about that kind of thing
Yoshi: and I know you hear it a lot and I just wanna know
Yoshi: what ki- that- why- what that feels like
Yoshi: like to have so many people come up and tell you
Yoshi: "oh you got me through such a rough time, you picked me up when I was feeling down", things like that
Yoshi: Like how does that actually feel.
Mark: It's- It's just like, "I did? Me?"
Mark: "I did that" like it- it's kinda that feeling
Mark: we- we often don't know how to respond,
Mark: I mean I can't speak for you guys but it's like,
Mark: "Oh man, I- I did- I had no idea!"
Mark: "I- I shouldn't make so many dick jokes!"
*laughter*
Mark: like, this is more important than me
Yoshi: We love the dick jokes! we love the dick jokes
Mark (laughing): You love the dick jokes
Yoshi: keep making dick jokes, please
Mark: yeah, it- it's just, w- it's a humbling moment like
Mark: it's- it's a series of humbling moments like
Mark: i- i- it's that stuff that keep us- keeps me anyway
Mark: I- I- once again I don't want to speak for, everyone but
Mark: it keeps me, and us grounded like
Mark: we- we- we realize the importance of what we're doing here,
Mark: and, also the non-importance, like the silliness off it,
Mark: like the aspect of the free-heartedness is also what makes it so,
Mark: like beautiful in a way, a- and we honoured,
Mark: that anyone could take more than just some cheap laughs out of our videos, so
Mark: like thank you, and- I'm glad that I could help.
Yoshi: I love that, I really love that
Mark: about a week ago-
*applause*
Wade: I mean,
Wade: I'd say it's motivating. There are days, where it's like,
Wade: We don't feel 100%, and we're kinda low on energy and it's like,
Wade: Enh, do I really wanna record today
Wade: and sometimes we don't, but I- we still manage to get our videos done
Wade: I get my two out a day, and everything else,
Wade: but, knowing that people depend on that, it's like,
Wade: it's such a motivating factor to not only, record and post our videos,
Wade: but also to be happy and enthusiastic it's like,
Wade: we know you guys are enjoying it and laughing and,
Wade: it's helping you guys feel better and get through like rough times in your lives,
Wade: So not only do I wanna make videos for you but I wanna be at my best
Wade: each and every time. So,
Wade: I don't wanna come in there and like
Wade (lazy voice): "Hey guys, uh, welcome back to whatever we're playing today I don't care, but"
Wade: You know, it's like I'm
Wade (excited voice): "Hey guys welcome back!"
Wade: and I, I just- I'm- I really am happy to be there cause I know that you guys are happy to be there
Wade: and you're enjoying it so for me it's motivating
*crowd cheers*
Bob: I'm just lazy ah- sorry I-
Wade: just lazy
Bob: I couldn't- couldn't regular clap for you
Bob: but uh, for me it's, uh
Bob: very similar to what Mark said, it's extremely humbling,
Bob: um, and it's also, it's sort of,
Bob: makes it easier to keep the message positive?
Bob: I guess this is exactly what you both said but,
Bob: there's a lot of times, where life gets you down,
Bob: or it gets me down anyway,
Bob: or I'm just like not in the mood
Bob: and I'm like "Man I wanna post this video"
Bob: and just like, aww just
Bob: t- talk some smack about someone or something,
Bob: and but it's like,
Bob: Remembering conversations like that, which, I re- I remember vividly,
Bob: because I always feel like I don't know what to say,
Bob: and it's very touching.
Bob: It reminds me that like,
Bob: What the channel is- supposed to be positive
Bob: Like everyone has negative stuff in their life,
Bob: and it's really easy, to just be like,
Bob: to just go out and bitch about something when you're in a bad mood
Bob: But, the channel, even- despite how I feel on any given day,
Bob: The channel is something that can be so positive
Bob: and it should be positive, because, it it-
Bob: it has- it can have an impact, which I-s- is shocking,
Bob: Is surprising, to me and to us, I think but
Bob: that- that's one of the most important parts of it
Bob: is the impact that it can have and it should be positive
Bob: So, that's my take.
*crowd cheers*
Jack: I mean, going off what they said, I agree with all of that
Jack: But to me it's it's super surreal, because-
Jack: Well, when you meet like people face to face
Jack: Everybody, like- the way you said it was like
Jack: "oh you're sick of hearing this" but the thing is like
Jack: Everybody has a different story,
Jack: You might have saved a lot of people,
Jack: and a lot of people might have liked your channel, but
Jack: They all like it in different ways, you've saved
Jack: or helped people in completely different ways all the time
Jack: You have people who have lost parents or partners
Jack: You have people who have gone through, battles with cancer or anything
Jack: So it like- There's a huge range to it but
Jack: At the same time like,
Jack: I don't wanna say Youtube saved me, either
Jack: because like, I was just in a cabin in the woods,
Jack: doing nothing with my life. And then-
Jack: I used to watch other youtubers as well,
Jack: and like, they stopped me feeling so alone
Jack: and I had something to do and they entertained me
Jack: So I thought, Why not do it as well and try and do the same for other people
Jack: So, it's really really humbling when you see
Jack: other people who have had that same experience
Jack: That, they're home alone and they just put you on in the background and,
Jack: I have a voice that fills a room of 12 people
Jack: Ah-um. But,
Jack: Yeah it it it's really cool, and
Jack: Like Bob said it keeps the message positive then,
Jack: and it keeps you grounded it keeps you humble as well
Jack: knowing that there's like
Jack: individual people like it may be 12 million
Jack: But those are all like single people
Jack: who have clicked Subscribe onto your channel
Jack: and who watch your videos so,
Jack: it's, it's crazy
*applause*
Jack: Thank you
Mark: Thank you very much
Yoshi: You guys are all so great you make like
Yoshi: You make my life so much better
Yoshi: Like so much better
Yoshi: Like if any time I'm feeling down,
Yoshi: I'm just like "Oh let's see if Markiplier's updated anything
Yoshi: or Jack or any of you guys it just like
Yoshi: it doesn't even matter, I just open up youtube
Yoshi: and one of you four, always pop up, and it's always, just, choice.
Jack + Mark: Thank you
*crowd cheers*
Yoshi: Um, and one more thing,
Yoshi: could I possibly get a picture with you guys
Yoshi: or do I have to wait until I randomly find you
Yoshi: at- at the convention
Mark: Unfortunately we can't now, like,
Mark: W-w- We have a lot of people that want pictures here
Mark: and I don't wanna be unfair to them or unfair to one
Mark: fair to one I dunno like,
Mark: We- You'll find us. We'll be around. We're here all week
Yoshi: I know, yeah. Everyone keeps- I was so jealous!
Yoshi: My friend last year, he posted a picture of like,
Yoshi: with you, and you guys are making funny faces and I was like,
Yoshi: "I'm mad, that's not fair, I'm so mad"
*background laughter*
Yoshi: Well I- we- we'll get a picture
Mark: Aww. We will
Yoshi: There will be funny faces
Mark: alright. Thank you very much
Jack + Yoshi: Thank you
*crowd cheers*
Wade: So, just let me interject,
Mark: yeah, go ahead.
Wade: We were talking a little bit, backstage um
Wade: Before we came out about the proposal and everything like that
Wade: and, it's ca- it's always been customary
Wade: We- We kinda debated this back and forth, but
Wade: it's always been customary that we've ask people if they have any special questions to ask on stage,
Wade: and we thought about, y'know kinda keeping it
Wade: Reserved, today?
Mark: m-hm
Wade: I- I feel wrong, doing that
Wade: because I feel like these are just such a special moment
Wade: for us as it is, that I dont' want to close it off to just me
Wade: I had my moment, in the light and,
Wade: I- if there's anybody out- I feel like we should- we should let them up
Mark: Might as well open the opportunity
Wade: Yeah.
Mark: They can say no, I suppose
Wade: So i-if anybody else out there has a special
Wade: special kind of question like I had today.
Wade: Uh. There's a lot of hands out there
Wade: I don't think you're all having those kinds of special questions
Bob: Man apparently this is a new thing everyone's doing it
Bob: i-oh.
Bob: Just stand up and come on down though
Bob: you know, you know who you are
Wade: If you, are here